hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and i've been buying
houses now for 12
years i've done over 300 property deals
and guess what
in this video right now i'm gonna be
answering your property investment
questions
so please do me a massive favor and
comment below your questions
any question around buy refurbished
refinance about
tax about deal sourcing flips best areas
hmos lease option agreements rent to
rents finding tenants managing tenants
anything at all
about property investment comment below
and i'll do my best to answer a little
disclaimer is
i'm gonna be answering based on my
experience and
my opinion of course you have to make up
your own mind
when deciding what to buy what to invest
in and how which tends to choose
but i'm just going to be doing my very
best to use my experience to point you
in the right direction and give you some
guidance
so please do me a big favor as well
comment your questions but also hit the
like button
and also subscribe to the channel which
you can do below so that you don't miss
a future
video let's see what questions we've got
from last week and while i'm answering
these questions from last week
maybe you'll have an offshoot of a
question because one question might lead
to another question
go crazy in the comments i'll do my best
to answer every single question that i
possibly can
so we have a question from last week
that says i'm about to get my very first
rent to rent congratulations
it's a five bed house and doesn't have a
hmo license
when i apply for the hmo license how
quick will i be able to move tenants
into the property assuming i've already
sorted out fire doors etc
so the good news is when you apply for a
hmo license
you don't need to wait to be for your
license to be to be given to you
you just have to apply and then you can
start renting out the rooms
straight away so that's really good news
um
do be guided by your local council um
and of course make sure that you've
submitted the
license application before you start
renting the rooms out but you do not
need to wait
until your license has been approved all
right next
svetlana carter thank you for the videos
you put out every day
do you know what's the best way to
increase the credit score
and how important is it in getting a
mortgage
so having a good credit score is
extremely helpful when you're a property
investor and you're buying properties
and ways to improve your credit score
number one don't have any unpaid
debts i'm not talking about debts that
are
you know um like you could have a debt
on a personal loan or you could have a
mortgage
that's a debt but then you've got debt
that's unpaid when it should be paid
overdue debts should we say so an
example of this would be
i had a phone mobile phone and there was
a little bit of a problem when i
canceled the contract
i couldn't cancel the contract i kept
trying to cancel it and they were making
it difficult
and they were saying you need to cancel
you can only cancel by
cancelling on the 30th and i kept
forgetting to cancel on the 30th and it
was just
in my opinion it was a little bit um of
a bad
network and in the end i just i just
said look i'm cancelling
please cancel my direct debit and oh you
need to call us on the 30th and i just
cancelled it myself
and then what happened is because i
didn't cancel it properly because i just
counted it at my bank
and then i got a new phone contract and
moved on um i ended up owing them
like 12 pound 50 apparently
and they sent me a letter and 12 and i
just thought
i binned it whatever stupid company
now about six months later when i was
buying
one of my investment properties my
mortgage broker said to me
i'm really sorry but there's a problem
and
your lender is saying that there's an
outstanding debt that you've got and
and it caused an issue i suddenly got
really worried
i said what's the problem i've always
paid my debts i've always paid my bills
i've got no issues i'm always paying
time and they said well let's have a
look and we went through and we found
out it was this little mobile phone
um debt and because of that 12 pound 50
outstanding
i was being declined a quarter of a
million pound loan
to buy an investment property that was
going to make me about 50 000 pounds
in profit so i had to then
go to the shop i had to set on my 12
pound 50 bill
and then my mortgage lender said now
it's been settled we can continue and
all was all was good
but that could have scuppered my deal so
i think it's just really important to be
mindful of things
like that make sure that you do i
learned a big a big lesson from that
the importance of even if it's a really
small little thing
and even if they're in the wrong and you
think that i've been done over
just make sure for your credit scores
sake that you've got no unpaid
over late payments on anything
so get those paid off another thing to
improve your credit score is just simple
things like being on the electoral roll
if you're not registered to vote it does
not help your credit score at all
but i think most importantly i would
just register for a site such as
um experian um
or noddle i think it's called one that
one that one that we use
and it will tell you what your credit
score is and it will tell you ways to
improve it so it is important
if you have got a bad credit don't panic
there are things you can do
in property without any credit at all so
or you can join venture with someone
that's got good credit on certain deals
uh i hope that helps all right matt i
have 300 000 pounds cash to invest in
property
so i'm relatively cash rich
unfortunately i have also a poorly paid
day job that pays 20 000 pounds per year
how can i get a buy to let mortgage as
most want a job that pays at least 25
000 pounds a year thanks matt matt i
think you'll be okay
because a buy to let mortgage if you
were getting a residential mortgage to
living yourself
then you'd only be you'd be very
restricted on what you could buy
because if your salary is 20 grand
they'd only lend you
a very very small amount of money
however if it's a buy to let mortgage
you should be fine because buy to let is
a business
and as long as the lender can see that
the house that you're buying
they'll value it based on bricks and
mortar and then value
it based on the rentability on the
commercial aspect
your salary how much you're earning
they're not too concerned about so i'd
advise getting a good mortgage broker
and helping them work with you to find
the right mortgage
caveman is it harder to get a
multi-level mortgage for a first-time
buyer at 21 years old
um yeah it is if you're trying to get a
first time
property and you want to do it as a
multi-let
it's possible but it is hard you're
better off starting with a single let
and then moving on to a multi-let it's
not to say it's impossible but you will
find many lenders
will there'll be restrictions
fan gila do you arrange for reviewing
first and then discuss rent to rent
or once you get there
or should you discuss before you don't
you don't discuss rent to rent before
going to a property because
you want to do it in person but you
should definitely tell them that you're
not going to be living there yourself
and it will be a corporate let so i'll
just say
hey i love the property on 32 church
road is it still available
great i'd love to come and look around
listen i'm not going to be living there
myself it will be a corporate let but
i'm free next week
on tuesday or thursday which one's best
so i've told them i didn't make a big
deal i didn't have a discussion about it
and then when i get there i'll look
around and if it's suitable i'll say
great it looks really good
look as i mentioned on the phone i'm not
going to be living here myself it will
be a corporate let
um and i'll be putting i'll be putting
um you know people in here on short stay
lex
uh however i can guarantee the rent to
the landlord um
and i could i could do it over a long
term letter what's he looking for is he
looking for a long term let
um you know what's his situation and
then
start having a discussion easy peasy
burning desire
should we wait until property prices
start to go down again or
pay excessive prices right now like 95
000 instead of 80
80 000 on a two bed terrace down north
um the problem with waiting for house
prices to go down
is they might not go down ever we don't
know for sure
you're saying oh man 95 grand is
expensive compared to what it was it was
80 grand
maybe i should wait until he was 80
grand again but
if it was 80 and then it goes up to 95
it might just keep going up to 110
and then it might drop back to 95 and
then it goes up again to 150
it might never be worth 80 grand again
so
you know if you look back over history
look at people
in 2002
when house prices were going crazy
and they were like oh let's just wait
until they go back like they were in the
in the in the late 90s
well that never happened did it so i
would say
buy a property but make sure you're
buying it for cash flow
maybe by below market value make sure
it's cash flowing positive
but you'd be you you'd be you're being a
fantasy world
if you think that you can just wait and
it will be the price that you want it to
be eventually
because it might not shahid hussein how
do you find good tenants
i find good tenants by buying in decent
areas if you buy in
the middle of a red light district
benefit street
horrible area with broken glass
everywhere and mattresses in the street
and then you're trying to find a good
nice
working young family ain't gonna happen
right so the first thing is you want to
make sure that before you buy a property
you're buying in an
area where you and i'm not talking about
buying a really fancy area
because that won't make sense from a
return on investment point of view
you want to buy in an area that's not
great
but is maybe a little bit up and coming
where you are are going to get decent
tenants secondly is
you want to find a good management
company that will reference the tenants
vet them well and then thirdly rather
than finding good tenants
market the property and let the good
tenants find you
all right gonzalez thanks for answering
samuel
would i need a hmo license if i rent a
house
three beds live in one room and rent out
the others
no you generally speaking across across
the uk
you will not need a hmo license if
you're going to do that however check
with your council because
some areas have got very strange rules
all right last question
glam as owned how to find a pitch
for brr strategy i live in london and
everything is ridiculously expensive
how to find a pitch or a patch oh i'm
not sure what
you said pitch but i'm not sure if you
mean patch i'll answer both okay
so how do you find a pitch for the brr
strategy
um if you're pitching to agents i'm
really
this is i'm really not sure if you mean
pitch or patch if you're pitching to
agents for brr strategy how i do it is i
tell them i'm looking for flips
okay buy refurbished refinance rent it's
very simple you buy a house
you add value and then
you refinance it you need to push up the
value of the house
the exact type of property that would
work for a buy refurbished refinance
would also lend itself to a flip and a
flip is a property that you buy
do up and sell because you need to when
you do it up there needs to be profit
there needs to be some margin in the
deal so if i'm pitching to
estate agents for bio refurbished
finance i'm going to say to them on
stage and i'm looking for a flip
because that's the language that they
understand i'm looking for something i
can fix up and sell have you got
anything
that's how i pitch it to answer your
other question which i'm not sure if you
meant but patch how do i find a patch
for biorefurbish refinance strategy i
live in london everything's ridiculously
expensive
it doesn't matter if everything's
expensive if everything's if
the average house is a million pounds in
your area
in your patch well then you just find
something that
is run down and needs a load of work
doing that you can buy for
500 000 or 600 000 that needs
a couple hundred spending on it to make
it worth a million
and then you when it's a million you
refinance it
and then you pull out 750 and then you
rent it now you've got to make sure if
you're in expensive areas
that the end um not only not only is the
end value
you're able to pull your money out but
also you need to make sure that the if
you're refinancing it
the interest payments and the rent
you need to be in profit there's no
point refinancing a property to find
that your mortgage payments are going to
be a grand a month and the rent is going
to be
a grand a month because then it's just
going to the rent is just going to
pay for your mortgage and you're going
to have no money left over so
you want to make sure if you're doing a
brr
strategy in an area maybe if you're
doing it in london you want to make sure
that the rent is is going to be
making you a good profit maybe it's a
hmo property
maybe it's serviced accommodation i've
got a friend called tony who did
who did a deal like similar to this in
london really nice
very expensive three million pound house
i think it is now but
he's renting out a serviced
accommodation
broken it up renting out a service
accommodation he's making a profit of
five grand a month
so there really is no one patch for buy
refurbished refinance it depends on the
deal
but you need to know what you're looking
for do your due diligence and pitch it
right to agents
i'm out i'm done i hope it was helpful
comment your questions below
hit like and i'll see you next time